what's up what's up y'all already know
it's Amy Luciani the one and only bag
lady and I just tapped in locked in and
rocked the bootleg cave podcast
special guest in here you might know her
from uh Love and Hip Hop
which I have not watched in a very long
time I'm talking about like I don't even
know I think I might have only watched
the first season okay out of Atlanta I
think when it was like New York Jim
Jones was involved the first season the
OG's of it I think that's it yeah and
then I I don't know if I stopped paying
for cable or you gonna watch this one
check check me out on it uh Amy is here
appreciate you Luciani right yes Luciani
that is a serious uh gangster last name
I have a pistol on me right now and a
chopper in the trunk well we are in
California where it's a little bit more
hairy and the legalities of such things
this is not Atlanta not Atlanta I'm
definitely loving it though how you
liking Cali so far so good so I'm ready
to get outside okay
like outside just the world like no I
did that yesterday and the day before
I'm ready to a club scene
I mean you live in Atlanta you're gonna
get none better than a strip club there
oh there's nothing like a blue flame
here it's just it's nothing at all the
nightlife here is very disappointing
so what I'm gonna do after I'm done
working the next two days like when I
wanna you could go to like you know one
of these Hollywood clubs but they're
coming yeah
there's a place called uh Crazy Girls
it's cool
it's decent I don't want cool cab I'm
straight on that
yeah I mean you come from the epicenter
of
culture and Stripes yeah so anywhere you
go here anywhere you go here you'll be
disappointed disappointed I'm I'm
disappointed because when I watch a lot
of the Instagrams and my friends who
live here they look like they're living
the club life but now that I'm here
texting them everybody's like [__] it
ain't nothing to do here there's clubs
but they're just not clubs I would go to
unless they're paying me
I like that yeah I like like if I'm not
getting paid I'm not going or if it's
like my friends got an album coming out
or something pop out maybe yeah it's got
to be like a friend got it a Killer Mike
had a thing the other night and that's
my boy so I came okay but it was at a
funeral home oh wow so la is just a
place you just pop out it's not staying
it's just in and out I'm not getting a
section staying for hours late I I just
opened the nightclub in Scottsdale
myself so for me it's like I'm like in
the industry so I'm not going out I'm
tired really you know what I mean yeah
I'm really tired well I'm not from here
and I'm tired too but I want to go out
no go to Hollywood Boulevard did that
already you gotta oh I saw you by the
way did you shower before you came yes I
did because I was like what cause you
were laying on the street I did that was
yesterday okay I saw the pictures on
your story and it's a very very
unsanitary place I wanted to be a part
of it I saw Angela bass's name Martin
Lawrence yes I'd get very close to her
somebody might have died or bled or peed
or urinated it was three dots of blood
fornicated right on top of those Stars I
smelled it I think you're accurate yeah
no it's a Hollywood is what very wild
Place very uh it's so different I didn't
expect to see
it was just different I love it though
because I don't see it regularly did you
expect to smell so much human urine
um that was disappointing yeah
especially with me having larger
nostrils right
um You agreeing to write about no I
didn't
yeah it was just I don't know I like it
because it's different obviously in
Atlanta I'm around predominantly black
and a lot of hip-hop and a lot of it's
just it's a different smell so being
downtown I was like really let me blend
in here no jewelry on I just want to be
out here can anybody run up on you with
their CD yes of course somebody ran up
on me with a poem book
um just all type of strange things
happen that I enjoyed yeah so if people
don't know when you go to Hollywood
Boulevard there's a lot of rappers who
are not aware of the technological
advances in music anymore and they still
come up to you with a straight face yes
well this a burnt CD and they expect you
to give them your money for it with the
Sharpie marker written and I'm like what
am I supposed to like I can't even play
this in my car then you got a CD player
dude so
yeah but they at least trying they
trying to do this they're trying trying
to come over that question how long have
you been making music I have been making
music on and off I would say
10 years a little less than 10 years
um the last year I actually started
taking it much more seriously I was
doing a lot more writing and doing the
behind the scenes and
that was more easier for me because
obviously as an independent artist
trying to push the music and put myself
out there it's a costly thing to do of
course very costly and I know you know
so I made a decision about a year and a
half ago I'm like you know what stop for
a second [__] get your business
together get your life together first
because I wanted it so bad but just
being out of order not having the income
and just not having the
the business plan for real for real
because me showing up and being pretty
and corrupt that [__] wasn't enough it's
not enough still to this day so took a
little break off really got more
organized and yeah this is the this is
the rebranch this is the comeback of The
Comeback Kid so give me uh because I'm
not like I said I don't watch Love and
Hip Hop I haven't watched Love and Hip
Hop for years like I said I have zero
clue right who's on Love and Hip Hop
Atlanta besides you
how did you get on the show what's going
on on the show what's the story lines
are you sleeping with anybody's men or
their fights have you pulled someone's
weave off yet is anybody getting [__]
up or reunion shows give me the recap
first no sleeping with these Menses okay
so like ill no is a little scrappy on
there he is okay [__] shout out to him
see I know something yeah Scrappy is on
it um I can just say the ones who
they've released so far for the promo
that they released with myself on it so
for those people who know who've seen
the promo it's
um Erica Mena myself Erica Bank she's an
artist from Texas she's from Houston
from Houston she was dating finesse two
times yep so she and I already newbies
on the show oh so this is your first
year this is my first year okay my first
season wow season 11 first one they
finally got a real rapper on it so Erica
Mena was like she was uh like Safari she
was on was she on the old school the New
York one yeah she moved to Atlanta she's
been here for some years now wow yep so
she was dating Safari and out right
she was dating bow wow yeah she was
married to Bow Wow I think huh no I
think it might have been a marriage
no I didn't who was she who was she yeah
I know she dated Bow Wow you just
brought that back to my mind and then
she was dating the chick
she was dating the chick yep that was in
New York she was dating the chick jokes
ended up being Joe Budden's baby mama
you are right so she might have been
married to Bible you know some [__]
yeah it's it's crazy I was intertwined
on this show I I'm typically standing
there just looking at everybody like
left and right it's gonna be very
hilarious because it's like her love
history is like the scream tour meets
the Joe Budden podcast I like that sure
she and I just squashed our beef so I
was going to ad-lib and do some clowning
on her but I'm gonna try to keep it cute
we had a little small issue a couple
years ago they had to get addressed and
we are we're like 30 good now so 30 is
better than zero percent exactly so what
was the issue over
it was some petty I you know something
with some content
um I dropped a single and her team
reached out to the guy who did my
the image you know we found this nice
lovely big vault in Atlanta no artists
no one had shot there and then I found
it and heard people reached out and then
she reposted it the next week and of
course fans and supporters were in the
comments like Amy did it first Amy did
it first oh she like went and shot in
that the exact same place the exact same
thing yeah so some petty girl [__] but
when the shade room reposted it I
commented on there and then she
attempted to change did you guys fight
no we didn't fight I gotta ask yeah I'm
just who knows rest in peace Jerry
Springer you know sometimes yeah you
gotta just duke it out yeah sometimes
you do but see I am honestly trying to
be on the show and not do that I've had
some situations but as I knew it would
come with it I'm not trying to scare the
money off I'm really on there for a a
bigger purpose to use the show like to
be a billboard wait cardi B was on it
right for sure and she made it it was
supposed to kicked the door down for
people to be like Ah that's a reality
show chick because yeah have cardi B's
yeah cardi B cardi B cardi B I can't
wait to get mine yeah she definitely
broke the mold I think a lot of women
get on the show and the money is good
and they become complacent because it's
like this is a job I get paid for and
there's no larger goal so
um the show has reached out to me three
times in the last five years so you had
said no prior two times yeah so so what
made it right this time to
um they're gonna showcase my music and
focus more on I told them you got catty
[__] on the show that do their things
they're already getting paid more than
me let them stay in their position and
then you got the newcomers like me like
I'm focused on the music the show flew
out to Texas with me
um they come to my studio sessions they
come to my rehearsals like I want it to
be about the music and you know in the
beginning it was like no this kind of
works what we're doing here so we want
you to do this and I just first two
times like no
um I'm making decent enough money
already without this so this go around
thank you they are focusing more on
really who I am in the music and not
kind of making me try to date somebody
or hang out with the [__] I don't
know they're taking it back so I think
how it started and I'm glad that they're
doing that this year so that's why I'm
gonna come on I do feel like when I walk
like would see shows like that I'd be
like it feels like so many of these
beefs and relationships and [__] are
just like four storylines
you know it's crazy I thought the same
thing until now that I'm in it it's real
it's really real but how it happens
which makes it kind of turn and look
like is this real
sometimes the beefs are so old and so if
this if I had this argument big fall out
with you three weeks ago we know this
happened the whole cast knows it and
then a month later when it comes out me
and you might have squashed it so I'm at
your listening party and it's like [__]
y'all were just on the show fighting on
Monday but but the episode is old it's
old people don't really know how it it
works as far as the process of rolling
out so you see us out with the person
it's like I knew that was fake it's no
way y'all was really arguing like that
but it was six weeks ago we filmed that
you didn't know that so it's a lot it's
definitely real you know you have some
who exaggerated but it's definitely real
uh talk about the music what do you got
going on on the music side what's on the
way what's out yeah yeah that part so I
just dropped a single car bag ladies
doing really good drop the video behind
it um shout out to bigger Rankin he
hosted this hey bigger ranking that's a
Florida Legend yes definitely did you
see the video yet I have not seen the
video you got to check it out let's
watch it together let's give you my
review hold on we got YouTube right here
right here let's watch it together let
me just angle and look at me
foreign
here we go God damn it why can't we have
a keyboard that connects to the [__]
TV
because it's on Amazon here
it's right there
wait the video's on Amazon the keyboards
are like oh the wireless one
you just hook it up look I see you there
you go right there
bag lady no okay featuring bigger Ranka
produced by mob Glizzy shout out to mob
Glizzy shout out to bigger
[Music]
he's so old man shout out to him bro yo
G for real
yeah
is that your baby
okay
you're like hey you know what give me
that baby great for the video
I was like against your mind
you have great abs
free I've been working for you those are
natural yes well you know I gotta ask
these days sometimes there's these girls
out here getting the
you can buy the ABS yeah [__] I've been
thinking about it and you might end up
looking like a lobster too I look like
that dude band man Kevo a lobster tail
look like a Ninja Turtle
I like this
look at that baby you don't want to be
there though
and that lady still hits me on Instagram
it's so funny she's like your nephew's
like five months now I'm like oh yeah I
love it
it was so cute though
fire you [__] with it I do and I and you
give honest so I would I would tell you
otherwise I like it
where'd you find the money room on peer
space so that is one of my mom's
businesses it's on peer space it's
called the pink and blue house so it's
um the first ever uh pink and blue
gender reveal house the entire home but
at the top is four different rooms sets
different sets yeah she's getting that
money getting that money shout out to
Mom yes yes yes shout out to Mom too I'm
on the way I don't have an album on away
but I am dropping a six song EP called
Amy's World
um we release bag ladies just to set the
tone for the bars and the sound and now
we're about to drop a EP it's coming out
on June 13th which is actually the day
that the show premieres out
uh that part so yeah June 13th I'm
excited about that we actually completed
the
EP maybe two weeks ago we're doing the
process of everything getting mixed and
mastered and getting the visuals and
stuff together I'm excited to drop it
I'm excited to be a little more vocal
about music I think that personally
people have you me as like the social
media girl or like this popular YouTube
girl and this girl goes viral and it's
like yeah that's a part of me but this
is what I really do and I hadn't really
put real energy into it because life how
it lives so this EP is important to me
because what's up y'all we gotta stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about our good friends at my bookie
that's right it is NBA Finals you gotta
Hammer the Nuggets I don't know they
might sweep the the heat I would look at
the
like serious odds on that go to my
bookie right now let's get some money
man all right baseball of course is in
full effect we got Stanley Cup finals
NFL seasons on the way sign up at
mybookie.ag right now use the promo code
bootleg and you will get that first
deposit bonus all right look I don't
care where you're at you can go to
mybookie.ag Let's gamble on some sports
they got the casino you can do live
Blackjack you can do live roulette craps
you could do all kinds of slots and of
course bet on the NBA Finals bet on the
NHL uh Stanley Cup finals crazy shots of
the Vegas golden knights that's what I'm
rooting for and of course baseball
season man all right so look right now
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
uh and sign up when you do use uh that
promo code they're going to give you a
first deposit bonus straight to your
account free money all right mybookie.ag
go do that also got to give a shout out
to our family at Blue chew that's right
ladies and gentlemen it's getting hot
outside that means
I don't know what that means it's just
hot so I feel like when it's hot people
want to [__] more right so you know
fellas if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it happens to the best of us
I'm sure maybe you are old maybe you are
dealing with stress at work maybe you
don't want to sleep with the same lady
that you're married to over and over
need a little extra motivation to get
that thing stayed up you know what I
mean go to bluetooth.com use the promo
code bootleg and they'll send it
straight to your door three-month supply
of Bluetooth for free all right now
there's Bluetooth work yes it does
you're gonna get a free month supply to
be able to see for yourself blue
shoe.com promo code bootleg uh now if
you don't know what it is it is the same
active ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
but in a chewable form and you do not
have to go to a doctor's appointment all
right you do everything online you don't
have to go sit at a doctor's office and
talk to some old man in a lab coat about
your dick issues not necessary anymore
in 2023 all right so go to Bluetooth
sign up with that promo code bootleg get
a month supply for free let's get back
to the interviews so what do you do on
YouTube that goes viral like what's your
you because YouTube revenue is great you
said you're barely kind of taking music
seriously so what what is your stick on
YouTube
um this really is Amy's world it's the
life of me like a vlog I Vlog I travel
um I had goats horses you have goats and
horses I was the black girl in the
mansion with all the older black people
the youngest girl in the neighborhood
with gold to animals and real big yard
and I just had fun I was just spending
my money as irresponsible as I could
because I'm a little Detroit [__] who
came into little money I ain't know what
to do with it for a minute so I bought
animals and I kind of built like hola's
Ark in the background I like that I
built it and I was just bringing it how
many animals do you have had had how
many animals did you have
um at one point I had
six
um I had a horse I had a goat I had no
that would be five then I had a horse I
had to go I had two dogs I had a llama
that didn't even last like two days in
the house it's very illegal but you had
the Llama inside of your house yeah I
had my gold in the house in the house
and on the back outside of the house so
you would treat the goat like a dog he
was a dog we used to eat pizza rolls
together Hot Cheetos Good Vibes with my
gold but the Llama didn't last I didn't
know it was super legal to have certain
animals oh that's why I said six I had
um two Australian sugar gliders as well
rest in peace to both of them [__] how'd
they die yeah they llama killed there
what happened I was being irresponsible
that's not good and they're gone now
they're gone then they fly off did they
Glide off to heaven
yeah they flew off to Heaven your house
must have smelled crazy amazing really
it was amazing there's no way because
they didn't live in the house like if
you saw some of my content they were
always in the back I had them tied up I
was DJing this gig like a burner store
uh on Sunset maybe like a month ago and
this lady came in it looked like Erykah
Badu walking a [__] ghost it was a
dog
it was a dog she was walking it like it
was a [__] dog it was a crazy shirt
you could train him to be dogs though my
ghost name was go tavius it was like a
little goat and this fool was just like
she kept hitting him with the milk you
know yeah and then they're great pets
they're they're ever they're good pets
so do you have any animals left I do I
have um a dog now left what kind of dog
he's a golden doodle his name is algebra
algebra he's everything to me I love it
yes yes yes it's a golden doodle that's
not like a small dog that's like a
pretty
decent size like when he stands up he's
in my face okay so you don't have like a
little pomeranian like a little no I had
actually the miniature version of him
but with me and my ex split up um it was
like this he took the dog fight over the
animals so he took the goats no he
didn't take the ghost I sold the Mansion
moved into a condo and all the animals
just one by one I was like okay I'll let
this one go okay I'll give you this who
got the horse back the lady who sold
them to me okay so she kind of hit a
lick she sold them to me and got him
right back do you so you are you like a
s escort how do you say esquitarian
esquitarian can you ride a horse yes so
you know how to get on the horse yes I
showed that on videos I used to um train
with the horses the lady who I would buy
a lot of my animals from animals from
um I would train with the horses and I
used to ride a blonde a blind horse a
blind horse oh wow that's [__]
awesome yeah that's like butt is that
awesome he doesn't crash because the way
you you know obviously because you're
you're steering him and they listen yes
and they hear so well because he can't
see so he actually can almost from
vibration feel where the fence is coming
and I used to ride a blind White Horse
wow yeah it's better than riding a blind
white man
I wouldn't mind if he if he was rich
enough there we go you know because he's
blind you could get away with so much
and he don't even know the money I'm
taking because you can't see it she
could be like oh who's here dog just the
the house cleaner
and so he has the upgraded Braille and
it's the upgrade don't forget yeah they
got Braille they know what's up did you
have you ever seen Yellowstone the show
no with Kevin Costner no makes me want
to learn how to ride horses it's a
current show with Kevin Costner yes and
he's a horse rider in the show he owns a
ranch it's like it's like a power
for white people I was about to say it's
giving super white but might be
interesting people people love it really
people love it like all people love it
Yellowstone after seeing Kevin Costner
played a role with Whitney
um yeah bodyguard I don't want to see
him ride horses you'll you'll I want him
to be like the black woman savior again
in another movie I loved that energy he
gave that one great movie so horse
riding Kevin you should you should watch
it it's really good it's some games
they'd be killing [__] and oh
okay I will watch that dude it's [__]
wild and is he doing on horses he like
riding about shootouts and horses I mean
it's a current Day show
but he's running this big Ranch in
Montana and it's just like some gangster
[__] he'd be killing fools and I'll
definitely check that out dumping their
bodies over the cliff and yeah cause
Kevin he he's not gonna be on a weak
[__] so it's like season five it's
really good and what is it on it uh see
that's where it gets complicated see
it's on Paramount plus but if you have
peacock you could watch the first four
seasons I have peacock then you can
watch I'm gonna watch when I get to the
crib yeah what's the best streaming
service in your opinion
um Netflix because I'm a documentary
person that's all I watch I love to
watch the
weirdest things on Netflix that most
people don't watch like I love hoarder I
love intervention you ever see the
Hoarders episode where the chick had a
bunch of jars around [__] all over our
house I did [__] I did I saw the
Hoarders where the lady was so obsessed
with animals that when they would die
she couldn't get rid of them so she kept
all of them like in these jars and boxes
hoarders gives me anxiety because I my
aunt Wendy's like that she's one of
those people so she's like a real real
hoarder she's like a white like white
trash really yeah is it is the is the
hygiene's given questionable in the
house oh it's [__] up it's [__] it's
[__] up my Wendy's house is a [__]
it's a [__]
I feel like I smell it almost now I shot
a music video in her backyard
with the Ritz who's from Atlanta who's
from Gwinnett County white boy named
Ritz rapper dude big hair uh we shot a
video in Arizona and her backyard and
everyone was always asking like bro
where'd you [__] find that place it's
a [__] up place you got shot outside
my aunt's backyard I know they fell
through like oops I'm like yeah all that
[__] was not a set that's how she's
living yeah and aesthetically it worked
for the video obviously for you to go
there yes because the the video was
supposed to be a uh do you ever watch
Breaking Bad No with Walter White
cooking meth so it's a math Centric song
okay yeah you have to go my aunt's house
is a math Centric home
I hate you right now okay so I was like
I got the perfect place guys wow perfect
place you ever hear somebody describe
something you kind of like smell it
almost
I picture it for some reason I feel like
I know how the house looks it's [__]
up
yeah it's [__] up I'm surprised Ryan
Woody's been she's been sued and evicted
from every place she's ever lived in
since I've been a child wow it's [__]
I don't know how she's living where she
is now because I drove up I had to just
drop something off like a month ago
and the front yard was so [__] full
of [__] it was [__] insane I was like
she came out I said what the [__] are
you doing here
what the [__] going on what is all
this [__] it could be some personal
stuff here I am being the one making
excuses for all women doing crazy I love
it anything else
um I love
any documentary about drugs nice I
actually like that do you do drugs why
smoke marijuana any uh any shrooms
so you look you like the shroom and I'm
going to shroom once my workload is over
tomorrow it's already in the books and
prepared
Truman and grooming is what I'm [__]
doing in California the next couple days
hey Cyrus reach into that trash bag over
there expeditiously Cyrus
because he's about to give us some real
[__] no the trash bag
the real to the to the right
the real boys like really digging the
trash for me
oh wait a minute wait a minute we're
about to shroom it up
now hold up
see I'm gonna say some real [__]
I feel like white boys versus black boys
y'all gonna do it the full way in the
right way like so these who would pull
this out other than you other than you
this is uh
albino penis envy
penis envy yeah so if you see it's
shaped like a little dick let me see
this little dig this is like somebody I
mean I mean a couple of the gummies now
this is like somebody I used to date
with this little this little size look
just like his [__] what uh ethnicity was
the guy with a little dick he was black
which was so disappointing how to be
disappointed right no it was
disappointed that he got some in that
dick these are gummies so these are not
as you know you could eat those well it
looked like you just took the bag of
shrooms away real quick that's so we'll
take those and we make these
yeah
Truman gummies yeah all for me thank you
I will indulge in these for sure
starting tomorrow
so are you telling me that the
stereotype about black guys having
not always true and it's so bad because
like us as women we don't want to give
give it to somebody who just like you
know if I knew that dick was like that
little shroom you wouldn't have got it
but guys y'all have this thing y'all can
do it can look big and bulky and then
you grind and it's like yeah he's gonna
put that work on me and then that little
shroom Dick came out but now it's
already going
send me at this point oh little barely
feeling anything really I'm here now
finish it I'm disgusted block them so
after that it's done it's a wrap I'm
disappointed I'm in the mirror this just
depressed why did you go for it like
make up with it with the motion in the
ocean not there was no motion oh so he
was really bad little shroom dick big
balls couldn't [__]
terrible fine as hell you're just a
waste of life right now wow because I
would assume
if you it's almost like when a girl is a
little heavier right yeah you would
expect her uh talents in uh certain oral
aspects to be great not her if they're
not uh but you know uh if I had a small
deck which I don't but if I did I would
assume that I would be sure to like what
are the things I can work on in the
bedroom to just use your mouth the whole
time right but see how we hear him at
least decent I didn't want the mouth oh
because I felt like I'm laying here and
you could actually speak and stop this
and be like I know I made you go all out
and do all this but I didn't know you
had that little shroom dick with them
big balls what a poor guy but but here's
the thing for guys I want them to know
if you know you got a little shroom dick
big balls or small balls with a shroom
dick use your mouth we will actually
come back and be like save you as like
my head Boo and you'll enjoy it you know
your dick is little so you don't really
want to whip it out so just head head
head all day damn don't get confident
and whip that little thing out in the
dark like that so that would be your
advice for men with small dicks head
don't even take it out why would you hmm
why would you so they're doomed
or this is me but they're kind of doing
or they gotta kind of find somebody who
hasn't seen a lot and they might be like
oh this is what they all look like and
that could be their wife who don't even
know nobody I have a really good friend
of mine uh who's dating a serious woman
and I happen to know he's
shout out to Nico Blitz my guy I was
like he's gonna say a name Nico is
[__]
you know let's just say some stereotypes
are true he's an Asian guy and I his
girl was very happy with him is she yeah
but what if he like got that
if you knew Nico you would know he ain't
got that he ain't got that and she's
happy they love each other
Nico can suck the hell out of here let
me open this door he can suck the hell
out some cats and that's why she is
there
you need to know that suck in the Caps
sucking the hell out of it he has to
because you can make up for it but don't
be just overly confident still trying to
hump
don't do that I've had that done have
you ever seen a guy who's a grower not a
shower I have pulls it out and you're
like yeah but then it's it's going and I
have one of those guys and you're like
oh [__] where did this guy come from
yeah but it's annoying yeah just to see
it have to grow is everything about it
well you know I'm a gem and I'm very
picky I'm very like
it has to grow because when you drop
your drawers and that little come out
and you gotta watch it grow
um
so I have to make it grow
are we oh I'll take one with you you
could just look at them and tell Kev
you're a guy you're not looking enough
like we are we can look and tell you'll
be able to tell
like I see the potential where that and
the person I'm talking about who got me
that time he's the only human in life
who has got me like that because I see
where I went wrong y'all wear them loose
little shorts joggers he's still single
he probably is still single but he was a
beautiful man he was so fine I was so
disappointed and he wore these
particular little shorts you know how
y'all know how to do that you got the
the joggers and unless the the dick plop
around
so you know them joggers the gray ones
yeah I mean I
um you have it there I'm sure I just
have whatever they send me in the mail
for free I like that those joggers trick
us every time and I was tricked I was a
victim of the gray jogger trick I
learned it now not obsessed fully before
we take it to so you couldn't be with
somebody who's not no I'm not gonna
waste his time rich
he will definitely be getting cheated on
on his business trips he might not ever
find out because he's Rich again right
but he will definitely have a very
Unfaithful but loving girlfriend oh
for sure
rich and what it's what if it's the Rock
he will have a very Unfaithful but great
girlfriend I feel like it'd be hard to
cheat on the Rock why because everyone
would know you're dating the rock so it
hit the tablets eventually oh no it's
always some Rudy Pooh [__] in the
corner ready to
it's always one in the corner what if
you what about Michael B Jordan you fall
in love with Michael B Jordan he's a
beautiful man but but it's just I'm not
saying that this is the case because I
would assume with his track record he's
probably doing his thing but let's just
say
hypothetically speaking
that would be hard he would have a
beautiful Unfaithful but great
girlfriend he would never know the level
of my infidelities there would be some
[__] in the corner probably with way
less than him breaking my back on the
weekends why he's and he would jump
through hoops to save his heart to make
sure he didn't get his heart yeah he
don't deserve what I would put him
through with that little dick he does
not deserve it but he would definitely
yeah I'm good on it I'm I'm into I like
to be on my person I like that okay yeah
well you're simple the uh season
premiere and your EP comes out June 16th
13th June 13th yes Amy's World Amy's
world is my world and I'm I'm letting
y'all come into it any features no
features on this one you and Erica Banks
uh gonna do anything
watch the season yeah you guys end up
fighting who watch the season do you
guys end up fighting watch the season
got to stop the interview to tell you
about our family at Odd Socks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
world ladies and gentlemen uh go to odd
socksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg Kev or bootleg both promo codes
work you'll save 20 out at checkout uh
20 off these are the Odd Socks Basics
all right now you can get like a pack of
all black pack of all whites of course
they got all kind of crazy licenses WWE
Cheech and Chong they got Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles they got SpongeBob
SquarePants bruh look they got the
SpongeBob SquarePants Krabby Patty
draws
yeah yeah now you don't want crabs but
you do want Mr crab's underwear because
these are fire all right so look go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code uh bootleg save 20 off of
checkout and uh yeah listen trust me
when I say most comfortable socks you'll
ever put on your [__] feet
and the most comfortable boxer briefs
what are we talking about man all right
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off of checkout great gift and
and just treat yourself all right uh
also
got a shout out to our family a King
Palm now if you guys don't know about
King pong kingpong is all natural baby
yes all right we're talking about the
leader when it comes to uh tobacco-free
natural organic Leaf wraps if you're a
smoker a toader a straight west coaster
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into King Palms they got it for you
what's great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying
and then you got flavor I'm going to
show you what it looks like when it's
stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms baby you already know what it
is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout half
off at checkout
50 off if you go to kingpom.com and use
that promo code the promo code is down
below go run it up try some of these
flavors too man the peach pineapple the
Strawberry Shortcake they just got so
much going on there's also all kind of
dope smoking accessories you can get
half off y'all what are we talking about
save 50 off kingpom.com promo code below
it's either bootleg or bootleg have them
these promo codes got my head hurt try
both of them all right one of them get
you 50 off God damn it anyway let's get
back to the interview is a lot of the
girls trying to team up and um she's a
nice girl take the talent The Talented
girl out and it's cute and I'm loving it
wait so Erica Banks and you got you guys
have a conflict this [__] this season is
there a conflict
it's given watch the season and you'll
you'll see what's happening here it's
a lot of girls fighting for that
position and the position is mine
and there's a lot of girls fighting for
it and I am who else is rapping on the
show that's a woman
um you have
spice she's an international
um artist spice I've heard of her
you have who else is
I was about to be Shady I'm working on
the level of shade that I give so I'm
gonna minimize this about 40 you have uh
Carly Red on there still she's been on
the show for a long time and she's
rapping now okay okay so you have her
and other than that you got some the
guys on the show of course you got
Scrappy you got chaotic he's from Miami
he's a rapper
it's I don't know it's just weird
everybody's like once they got the bag
they just said I actually want a rap now
it's weird and I'm just there watching
it and just trying to focus on my
situation but it's gonna be an
interesting season so June 13th I
definitely think people are going to
enjoy what they see all right well go
check it out I appreciate y'all watching
another interview brought to you by our
good Folks at hardean now listen y'all
when you're in Las Vegas you get in that
[__] Uber you land at the airport hit
that taxi tell them to take you to hard
Dean the number one premium cannabis
dispensary in the [__] world y'all
I'm telling you you walk in they treat
you like a king or a queen or whatever
you're into all right they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
you'll see period anyway let alone in
Las Vegas but just anywhere all right
not only can you go get the best tree
you'll get the best experience the best
customer service the best bud tenders
you walk in the hard Dean and that [__]
just smells amazing they got their own
[__] scent literally you get into my
car I got a bottle of it my car smells
like Harding because it's just the best
[__] place go follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinlasvegas.com all right when you go
you're in Vegas you pull up tell them I
sent you they're going to take care of
you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hardine all right you gotta
go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank you all
man I love these guys they're like
family to us and uh hey we're gonna drop
another interview soon if you're
watching this you're at the end of the
interview though much love